londres envisage de proposer des
passeports à des millions d'habitants de
hong kong est impossible d'accès à la
citoyenneté britannique
le but faire fléchir la chine qui
persistent imposé au territoire sa loi
sur la sécurité nationale quelques trois
cent cinquante mille personnes en compte
détiennent actuellement le passeport
britannique d'outre-mer cesson qui donne
l'accès sont mises à la grande bretagne
pour un séjour allant jusqu'à six mois
deux millions et demi de personnes
seraient éligibles à une demande
d'obtention de ce document délivré donc
aux habitants de l'ancienne colonie
britannique s'étaient en 97 lors de sa
rétrocession à la chine
boris johnson s'est donc déclaré hier
ouvert à accorder des droits
supplémentaires aux détenteurs hong kong
et de nombreuses personnes à hong kong
craignent que leur mode de vie que la
chine s'est engagée à maintenir le soin
me lasser si la chine impose sa loi sur
la sécurité nationale le gouvernement
britannique modifiera sa législation sur
l'immigration et permettra à tout
détenteur de ces passeports résidant à
hong kong de venir au royaume uni pour
une période renouvelable de 12 mois est
d'obtenir d'autres droits y compris le
droit de travailler ce qui les mettrait
sur la voie de la citoyenneté la grande
bretagne n'aurait alors pas d'autre
choix que de maintenir ses profonds
liens d'histoire et d'amitié avec le
peuple de hong kong n'en parla en direct
avec jean françois di meglio c'est le
président de l'institut de recherche
asia centre
bonjour merci et d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors cette
proposition est qualifié d'ingérence par
la fim comment appréciez-vous ses propos
si on prend le propos de la chine à la
lettre la chine effective en fait valoir
ce qu'elle a obtenus lors des accords de
1984 et fameux accord qui prévoyait la
rétrocession en 1997 et qui établissait
le principe de un pays deux systèmes
ce que les britanniques ont hésité à
octroyer aux résidents de hong kong en
ils prétendent aujourd'hui l'octroyer
voyez maintenant 37 ans après près de
trente sept ans après c'est les années
accord de 1995 qui sont en cause en fait
il y avait des résidents à hong kong qui
bien sûr vais beaucoup de restrictions
pour venir au royaume-uni puisque
c'étaient des citoyens de seconde zone
c'était l'occasion en 1984 pour ouvrir
la porte
naturellement les accords satcher dans
le shopping de 84 ont été beaucoup plus
mal luzien que ce qui étend aujourd'hui
proclamé parcours y sommes d'une
certaine façon et qu'un est dans son
droit en rappelant ce principe là bien
sûr à cette époque là madame thatcher se
laver un peu les mains de ce qui pouvait
arriver aux résidents de hong kong
boris johnson pour toutes sortes
d'autres raisons aujourd'hui en
particulier parce qu'il se dit
probablement fait talents venant de hong
kong serait des talents intéressant à
récupérer dans une angleterre qui fait
face aux briques side vient il a changé
d'avis ce sera difficile bien sûr de ne
pas accepter cela
sans faire une crise avec pékin c'est en
tout cas que pour un jeu parce qu'il l'a
il ouvre la possibilité d'une crise avec
pékin aucun grand pays occidental n'a
aujourd'hui ouvert ce niveau là mais
pourquoi maintenant les accorde 84 date
donc de 1984 y avait un principe un pays
deux systèmes qui n'avait jusque là pas
été remis en cause en tout cas par les
britanniques pourquoi maintenant
précisément eu depuis plusieurs
occurrences la dernière étant en 2014 la
toute dernière étant d'année dernière
eh bien on se rend compte qu'il y a un
pays deux systèmes
mais deux interprétations différentes
aussi de l'accord qui maintient jusqu'en
2047 le statut à hong kong de
législation indépendante et
d'indépendance relatif par rapport aux
juridictions du continent aujourd'hui ce
que fait pékin ce que pékin a essayé de
faire plusieurs fois
est ce que pékin fait de nouveau depuis
c'est d'unifier les juridictions hong
kongaise et continental si on peut dire
c'était tout à fait prévisible le
royaume uni faisait semblant d'une
certaine façon de ne pas savoir chris
patten était le dernier gouverneur de
hong kong a tout fait pour préserver les
intérêts bien sûr des ddd hong kong est
mais il y avait un certain nombre de
choses écrites
donc pourquoi aujourd'hui probablement
parce que effectivement il y un climat
qui se retourne contre la chine ces
temps ci à toutes sortes de titres
peut-être que boris johnson en a besoin
aussi du poids de l'opinion publique
mais probablement trop tard et trop peu
alors effet d'annonce cette proposition
vaut boris johnson
il va aller jusqu'au bout alors il va
faire constater quelle est l'ampleur du
différend qu'il ouvre avec pékin au
moment où il le fait s'il a
effectivement le la tenue et s'ils
décident à l'endurance pour maintenir un
relatifs à frottement avec pékin ce
n'est pas un effet d'annoncé
si effectivement pékin menace d'un
embargo ou de mesures de rétorsion il
faut se souvenir que il ya en
particulier une centrale nucléaire
déjà en cours de route avec un
investissement chinois à la clé en
partenariat avec edf y en a une autre
toujours donc temps là dans la filière
nucléaire qui se négocie entre edf
angleterre et la chine bon ça se seront
effectivement d arme de négociation que
la chine pourra voir il faudra voir si
boris johnson considère que cette
négociation vaut la peine d'être mené ou
pas